dans cette usine de la ville d'idlib des
femmes et des hommes produisent à la
main des masques de protection
objectif répondre à la forte demande et
éviter d'importer des masques hors de
prix en raison de la propagation du
coronavirus qui arrivent dans les
régions du nord de la syrie et de la
zone libérée dit libre les masques
étaient très demandés tous les points de
passage avec damas ont été fermées par
conséquent nous ne recevons plus de
produits de premiers soins ni de masquer
ce qui entraîne une forte demande
nous avons alors eu l'idée de commencer
à produire des masques ici à la main et
nous à l'aide de machines 50 ouvrières
et ouvriers travaillent dans l' usine
avec des enfants qui viennent prêter
main forte au quotidien ce sont vingt
mille masques de protection qui sont
produits lorsque l'épidémie sera terminé
je pense que je pourrai dire que j'ai
contribué à ma manière même si c'était
mineur en fabriquant des masques en
prévision de la propagation du virus
dans notre pays
des masques bienvenue dans la province
d'idlib où le co vide 19 menace tout
particulièrement ici le long de la
frontière turque plus d'un million de
civils s'entassent dans des camps des
femmes et des enfants en majorité qui
tente de survivre malgré un accès limité
aux soins et à l'eau potable un secteur
où des dizaines d'hôpitaux sont
désormais hors service en raison des
bombardements et des combats